Chinese spy balloon over central USA
will be in U.S airspace for a few days
Pentagon says this is a February 3rd
story so it's an older story so defense
department spokesperson General Pat
Ryder said Friday that the Chinese
surveillance balloon hovering over U.S
has moved into central part of the
country but the client again to
specifics no problem the balloon is
currently flying about 60 000 feet above
sea level higher than civilian aircraft
the Biden Administration has condemned
the presence of a China surveillance
aircraft in the U.S airspace as a
violation of U.S sovereignty but nothing
happens okay same day Trump says shoot
down the balloon okay president Trump on
Friday called for the U.S to shoot down
the suspect of China's high altitude
surveys surveillance balloon that had
been spotted flying over different
states in the recent days shoot down the
balloon Trump posted on this truth
social Office of Naval intelligence
veteran human events senior editor Jack
basobic agreed with former president
assessment writing you shoot down the
balloon and launched bombers from Guam
that's gonna that's what you do when
Homeland is threatened Stephen Miller
trumps former senior advisor for policy
and White House director of speech
writing blamed current President Joe
Biden's weakness for the decision to not
shoot down the balloon okay so then this
continues U.S military shoots down
Chinese spy balloon over Atlantic Ocean
do you guys want to shout it down while
the balloon was off the coast of South
Carolina the balloon was shot down by
U.S military fighter jet on Saturday
afternoon senior defense officials said
during the Thursday afternoon briefing
that the U.S government is confident the
surveillance balloon is from the people
Republic of China senior U.S officials
said that the government was considering
a plan to shoot the balloon down while
it's over the Atlantic where it wouldn't
harm any individuals on the ground
official added that the U.S government
could potentially recover uh the balloon
and then there's even uh comments about
the fact that China wasn't happy that we
shut it down see that story where why
would you shoot down the balloon yeah
they said that they might might even
take action against us because we shot
down their a spy balloon over our
country and we also can't seem to be
able to get a straight answer about
whether we in some way were able to jam
their transfer of information uh back to
China we don't we don't know the answer
to that exactly did they did they end up
picking up the balloon they said they
they were going to try to do that but
when it when they thought like like the
recovery after yeah I mean I'm pretty
sure they did but but I what I I failed
to grasp and understand is they well
they monitor everything it was it left
over an ocean if you wanted to knock it
down that's where you knock it down is
over that ocean not the Pacific before
it's not before it's starting so you're
basically giving people the green light
come come and spine I don't believe the
whole rhetoric of well we were
monitoring it they weren't really
looking at certain things that we didn't
want to it stopped over Great Falls
Montana right over a nuclear missile
base I'm not stupid I don't think that
people are stupid but the way that they
spin it it's trust us nothing we don't
want to blow up a balloon because we
don't know what's going to fall out of
it we're letting it come over but who
knows what could been on it who knows it
could have a bomb it could have anything
on it we have no idea China's pushing
the envelope because they know and you
mentioned that Roger from from the
Afghanistan withdrawal we have no idea
what we're doing uh uh Biden you kind of
invited uh Russia to attack Ukraine when
he said you know a minor uh incursion
wouldn't be you know we would tolerate
that he basically gave him a green light
and now something like this nobody
respects us when it comes to to defense
and they don't respect uh Joe Biden I
think it's showing when they're when
they pull off stunts like this it's a
test I think I think it's a test uh I
mean I don't think you can shoot down
the balloon uh in international you know
airspace but as soon as it was over U.S
Sovereign territory boom we had an
obligation to act uh and then just the
the more the days stretched out and the
whole country is like recording get on
their phone and there's more there's
more balloon memes than you could ever
see yeah they took over the egg memes if
you were to give it because you said
it's a test if you were to give the
Biden Administration a grade on how they
respond bonded to that test what would
that create it would be an F okay
it would be F because they waited so
long I mean I you know I I think you
have to move immediately on those things
and if it turns out to be true that
there were balloons over U.S territory
during the Trump presidency and some in
the military didn't tell the president
or the sect def because they feared that
he would do exactly that wow that's a
real problem no I think I think also
especially if you're saying like it's a
test what if they're trying to see what
how much they can do was still getting
away from it so if they were to do
something finally then the boundaries
already drawn so far out that they'd get
further Head Start in a sense before we
react because now it's like oh they can
go over our airspace they can do all
this this other stuff without Russ
really giving a reaction so then you've
kind of drawn the lines there yeah I I
think I think the biggest thing is
there's two things okay one is you go to
a place and to measure someone's
toughness and to measure you're
someone's the other I did a poll would
you rather be respected feared admired
and then there was another one loved
right and for whatever reason respect
was number one 55 and I think feared was
number three or something like that to
see those three again respected feared
admired and loved right
uh which by the way in a life uh you
know like a regular person just living a
life they're probably wanting to be
respected right which makes sense
but if you're a world leader you want to
be feared where people don't do anything
you're at a bar
you're sitting with your girl you have a
reputation
your girl's beautiful
so if a guy totally fears you and
respects you doesn't even talk to your
girl to come and say anything to her
right
if a guy is trying to see maybe you're
okay with it he'll come and be friendly
with your girl
but if she comes and says to you hey do
you mind if I dance also with your girl
he doesn't think you care if he dances
so not to some people like that's not a
big deal somebody has to dance also with
your girl
what China is doing right now is saying
I don't think he's gonna mind just put
the balloon out there they're not going
to do anything they're going to take
their time and they're going to think
about it because they don't want to make
the wrong decision so you know the whole
thing that indecision is more worse than
actually making a decision so this was a
sign of indecision we were afraid of
making a decision an unseen like the
other side is going to come after us no
you got to call the shots can you play
the can you put the Yahoo article I just
sent you on top right second one so Pat
comes Kamala Harris would be China and I
mean Kamala Harris's husband kissing you
know what I mean yeah exactly that's
exactly what that would be exactly what
I'm saying to you no you're right so
watch it so Yahoo story so go to the top
so we can see it to Yahoo story so this
is a yahoo story if you can just go up a
little bit yeah China is mad at the U.S
for blasting it's suspected spy balloon
but a few years ago State tv bragged its
fighter pilots could shoot one down okay
so so again China's met a 2020 Chinese
State tv clip showed off how fighter
pilots could shoot down surveillance
balloons the video shows a pilot
tracking and shooting a balloon during
an apparent training exercise China said
on Monday that the U.S shooting down a
suspected Chinese balloon was
unacceptable China is upset at the U.S
shot down the balloons TV got it the
video on China is encountered in the
video and alarm Bell prompts a fighter
pilot to prepare and board a fighter jet
and peers to be the Chinese j-10 a
multi-role got it a CCT never rid the
reaction saying that loading missiles
powering up checking the fuel uh uh uh
what what is the word right there the
few slage and other procedures were all
completed quickly so if you can go a
little lower to see who said they were
upset about the fact the supervising
command organized judged High
surveillance the CCTV the white balloon
Explorer and the launcher so they're
explaining what happened to it so who
who are these guys to say you're upset
that we shot down your balloon what do
you mean you're upset and who gives you
the audacity to even say something like
that they can you know we're upset that
you shut down the balloon what makes you
think we care yeah what makes you think
we care about your opinion whether we
shot it down or not who's a priority you
know I think it is our relationship with
you or protecting the safety of our
citizens are you out of your mind when
you make a comment like this but the
audacity
to even say something like that don't
care that's why but but I don't think
they can do that under strong leadership
I absolutely I don't think you can even
make a comment like that you know what
happened but you know what would happen
within 24 hours oh really no problem 25
tariffs exactly yeah that's what's going
to happen say that one more time to us
because without us China when you were
not even a top 10 economy in the world
just 50 years ago when uh your former
friend came and struck to deal with
those guys back in whatever the 60s was
you wouldn't even exist
on what you did you needed the help of a
smaller econ smaller Nation more
powerful uh economy to help you realize
that capitalism Works to be able to
compete with everybody else now you want
to talk to these guys like this you you
you America helped these guys turn into
what they are today and now they're
flipping and saying hey you disrespected
us it's an insult okay so if you enjoyed
this club you want to see another one
click here to watch another clip and if
you want to take advantage the latest
gold Signature Series products that just
came out we have a bunch of new merch
that's out this is a color changing mug
when you drink coffee that lion turns
into a real lion and then we have
hoodies with vitamin gold on it the gold
Signature Series hat shirts I'm an
entrepreneur anyways we have a lot of
items they're selling out if you want to
take advantage the gold Signature Series
click here place your order Sports your
right taming gear and tag us with the
hashtag valuetainment
[Music]